[Musique]
le 1er août 15 189 le dernier des valois
henri iii est en train de mourir
poignardé par un moine fanatiques
son dernier attentat que roy sera de
désigner sans aucune hésitation son
successeur son cousin henri de bourbon
roi de navarre
[Musique]
henri de bourbon est alors le descendant
direct le plus proche de louis 9 et du
capet et par là-même l'héritier légitime
de la couronne de france après avoir
assisté à la terrible guerre entre
catholiques et protestants
après avoir été emprisonné au louvre et
100 m échapper henri de navarre est donc
sur le point d'accéder au trône
mais la lutte n'est pas encore terminé
on lui dénie ce droit et le trône
restent vides
par la borderie 3 effectivement les
français se réveillent avec un souverain
qui a une religion qui n'est pas celle
de plus de 90 peut-être 95% de la
population
henry va devoir se battre durant cinq
ans avant de conquérir paris et la
couronne mais son règne deviendra l'un
des plus célèbres pour les français
comme pour les historiens
en quinze ans il va parvenir à
réorganiser à renforcer un pays qui se
déchire depuis plus de 30 ans et il
connaîtra une fin qu'il ne méritait pas
il sera poignardé dans son carrosse par
un fanatique pour des raisons que l'on
commence tout juste à comprendre
[Musique]
après 261 ans de règne et 13 monarque la
maison des valois branche aînée de la
dynastie capétienne doit céder le trône
à la maison des bourbons la france a
connu plusieurs décennies d'une guerre
civile impitoyable et pendant trente ans
elle a été dirigée par des rois d'une
grande faiblesse
il s'agit des trois fils d'henri ii et
de catherine de médicis françois 2
charles neuf et henri iii le pays a un
besoin urgent d'être repris en main par
un monarque fort attaché à la paix
capable d'unifier le pays et de lui
rendre sa prospérité
henri de bourbon roi de navarre à une
confiance absolue en son destin il se
sent élus mais sa foi protestante va lui
falloir encore un bon nombre d'années
difficiles car la mort du valois henri
iii n'a pas mis fin à la guerre civile
et henri iv n'a pour l'instant que le
nom de roi bien que la religion réformée
compte beaucoup de nouveaux convertis la
majorité des français reste catholique
depuis charlemagne et clovis avant lui
la royauté est étroitement lié à
l'église romaine après plus de huit
siècles de tradition ininterrompue
comment pourrait-on confié le trône à un
hérétique
ému par les derniers mots de leroy les
nobles accepte son cousin henri de
navarre
ils le considèrent comme l'héritier
légitime et lui offrent leur soutien
immédiat
puis tout aussi rapidement ils font
volte face et se déclare consternée à
l'idée qu'un roi protestant puisse
monter sur le trône de france et refuse
de le reconnaître comme henri iv à moins
qu'il ne se convertisse immédiatement au
catholicisme
non seulement cette année hrithik mais
c'est ce qu'on appelle un relapse
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui a été
catholique une partie de sa vie et qui
est revenu à l'hérésie
donc c'est encore plus grave henri iv a
changé une bonne demi douzaine de fois
de religion entre sa naissance et 489 et
donc ils ajoutent à la casquette si
j'ose dire de l'hérétique calviniste du
disciple de calvin la casquette de celui
qui d'une certaine façon on n'a pas
vraiment de religion qui est capable
d'en changer et il l'a prouvé maintes
fois 2 qui espérait un tel changement de
foie si ce n'est d'un homme qui n'en a
aucune le chef que les catholiques de la
ligue veulent voir succéder à henri de
guise leur héros assassiné et son frère
le très gros et très ambitieux charles
de lorraine duc de mayenne
il se proclame lieutenant général de
l'état royal et de la couronne de france
le parti de la ligue tente de faire
proclamer roi le cardinal de bourbon
sous le nom de charles 10
c'est l'oncle d'henri de navarre et il
offre à l'église la possibilité de
présenter au trône un héritier
parfaitement légitime mais il est âgé de
66 ans est toujours emprisonné suite à
son arrestation par henri iii il meurt
d'ailleurs l'année suivante à fontenay
le comte
en vérité il n'est qu'une figure de
proue utilisé pour gagner la couronne et
être remplacé ensuite par le duc de
mayenne où le jeune duc de guise
également séquestré à cette époque
philippe ii d'espagne depuis son palais
de l'escurial à l'audace d'ignorer la
loi salique et de suggérer que sa fille
l'infante clergé n'y monte sur le trône
vacant
elle est la fille de sa troisième femme
elisabeth de valois ce qui en fait la
petite fille d'henry 2 henri iv n'a
derrière lui qu'un sixième de la france
et une armée affaiblie par près de 20000
désertion on lui conseille donc
d'arracher paris à la ligue
il n'y a qu'un seul problème les forces
d'henri sont insuffisantes pour livrer
bataille ou assiégé paris à la mi août
le roi se dirige vers la normande ainsi
contrôler t-il bientôt les régions de
l'oise et de leurs dons paris dépend en
grande partie pour se nourrir de là ils
avancent vers dieppe prenant sans
difficulté les villes qu'il croise sur
son chemin et répandant la rumeur que
son but est de s'emparer de la ville
très catholique de roi apprenant cela le
duc de mayenne qui de paris et se dirige
vers la normandie comme henri l'espérait
celui ci va devoir affronter la
puissante armée de la ligue sans argent
avec une troupe réduite au minimum et un
ravitaillement de fortune mais son
tempérament de gascon lui interdit de se
laisser abattre ont dit qu il répondit
en apprenant à quel point ses
adversaires étaient plus nombreux vous
n'avez pas tout compte et vous avez
oublié dieu et la juste cause qui sont
de mon côté
le duc de mayenne qui remplace françois
de guise qui a été assassinée on le sait
à blois par henri iii lève ce sa grande
armée une armée qui compte deux fois
plus d'hommes que celle d'henri iv et
arrive dans la vallée de la béthune à
dieppe en régate se dit je suis moins
fort étant donné que je n'ai pas de
troupes suffisamment nombreuse donc je
vais être le plus malin et il prend
possession des ruines du château rohan
vieux château sur les eaux de dark qui
n'était pas encore arques-la-bataille
château construit autrefois par
guillaume le conquérant et ils
installent la son artillerie
il fait creuser des tranchées de plus de
deux mètres de profondeur et place ses
canons sur des collines stratégiques
autour de la vie d'arc dieppe qui est
sienne à présent étant derrière lui la
bataille d'arc démarre dans la brume
d'un matin de septembre
protégés par leurs fortifications les
troupes du roi vont tenir ferme contre
les vagues successives d'assaillants le
duc de mayenne est trop confiant et ses
troupes se révèle bien peu vaillante
quand le brouillard se lève les canons
du roi commence à frapper leurs cibles
depuis les collines avec une précision
impressionnante et avant midi la
bataille est terminée
ça ne fait pas une grande victoire est
lui bien d'autres batailles mais elle
eut un effet psychologique décisif
leroy gagne du terrain et prend de plus
en plus confiance il va être reconnue
est couronné roi de france sans avoir à
trahir sa foi l'espagne et rome sont
tenues d'aider la ligue
alors philippe ii d'espagne qui succède
à charles quint qui avait fait tant de
misères en faire soit premier envisage
lui naturellement de soutenir la ligue
des catholiques car c'est un roi
catholique et par la même occasion de
reprendre possession complètement de
tous les territoires qu'ils souhaitent
caresser et posséder en france donc il
se prête à la ligue dans l'espoir
certainement de voir la double et une
fois la victoire acquise
on rit lui reçoit le soutien des ennemis
de l'espagne et des amis de la réforme
les calvinistes landais les protestants
d'allemagne les anglais et les vénitiens
ne veulent pas que l'espagne s'impose en
france le pape sixte quint qui a
excommunié henry en 15 285 est assez fin
pour comprendre que la sauvegarde du
catholicisme romain n'est pas la seule
raison pour philippe de se mêler des
affaires de la france
il envisage à présent d'autoriser la
conversion d'henri de navarre comme une
condition préalable à son couronnement
enfin malgré la propagande massive de la
ligue une partie croissante de la
population affirment préférer voir en
france est futile hérétiques sur le
trône plutôt que de subir l'ingérence de
la monarchie espagnole
le français lambda se doute bien que
l'invasion espagnole pour regarder la
couronne catholique cache quelque chose
que c'est un jeu trouble c'est un c'est
interlope
c'est bien que philippe ii et son armée
l'espagnol n'est pas du tout du tout
bien apprécié sur le territoire
encouragé par la victoire et le soutien
de ses alliés
henry quitte arc et se dirige vers paris
il arrive aux portes de la ville le 1er
novembre avant le duc de mayenne et met
en place un siège qui paraît plein
d'avenir
mais à cause d'une erreur tactique un
pont qui n'a pas été sécurisés il doit
laisser paris derrière lui une fois de
plus il va passer les mois d'hiver froid
et humide à tour ce sont pour lui des
jours sombres dont sont absents l'humour
la chaleur et l'espoir qui le
caractérisait à la fin janvier 15 190
toute la normandie est quasiment sous le
contrôle du roi la seule ville encore
détenues par la ligue et roi henri
projette de faire sortir de paris le duc
de mayenne de le battre est de marcher
de nouveau sur la capitale le 14 mars la
ligue affrontent les royalistes près de
dreux dans la plaine de saint-andré
henry est de nouveau en sous-effectif
mais il sait aussi qu'il est le roi
légitime et qu'il est le seul à pouvoir
ramener la paix dans le pays
les paroles qu'il lance à ses troupes
avant le combat sont passés à la
postérité
si vous perdez vos enseignes vos cornet
tous vos bannières ralliez vous à mon
panache blanc vous le trouverez toujours
au chemin de la victoire et de l'honneur
le roi paie de sa personne dans les
batailles spécialement à evry et c'est
un grand événement militaire qui va
entraîner le ralliement d'une partie de
soldats une partie de grand seigneur qui
voit désormais un peu le vent tourner en
faveur de ce roi pourtant protestants
deux heures plus tard le chef de la
ligue se retire en abandonnant son
infanterie
c'est une victoire totale que l'on doit
au génie militaire et à l'héroïsme henry
avait repris confiance en s'emparant de
la normandie ils contrôlent maintenant
de nombreux points essentiels dont
dépendent les parisiens dont henry
placent paris en état de siège mais
l'assaut du 12 mai 15 190 est encore un
échec
la ville est bien défendu il met en
place un blocus en espérant que les
habitants finiront par se rendre au bout
de quelques mois le grand siège de paris
celui de 15 190 va durer plusieurs
semaines cela sera un siège terrible la
population parisienne
vas mourir de faim il y aura des
dizaines de milliers de victimes c'est
l'un des événements les plus tragiques
des guerres de religion
en août il semble sur le point d'y
arriver
quand le duc de parme arrive pour
libérer paris dans une brillante
initiative le duc prend durant la nuit
la ville voisine de l'ani construit un
pont de bateaux en travers de la marne
et entre dans paris avant même qu henry
ne la prenne quelques jours plus tard il
fait acheminer 1500 chariots remplis de
nourriture
henry se bat et gagnent des villes sans
grand intérêt militaire avant de se
résoudre 18 mois plus tard à tenter le
siège de la ville de royan tenu par la
ligue
mais les espagnols la soutiennent avec
ferveur
henry a donc besoin d aide l'allemagne
et les pays bas lui apportent leur aide
et la reine elizabeth d'angleterre
malgré ses réticences n'a d'autre choix
que de venir elle aussi au secours du
roi protestant pourtant encore une fois
henry et finalement doubler par le duc
de parme en avril 15 192 rouen libéré
henri réussit toutefois poursuivre la
ligue et les forces espagnoles et
infligent aux ducs une blessure mortelle
à laquelle il succombera un peu plus
tard
[Musique]
henri iii est mort trois ans plus tôt
l'image d'un trône vide commencent à
apparaître sur les pièces de monnaie
malgré ses succès militaires les
tentatives d'henry pour conquérir paris
se sont toutes soldées par des échecs
jusqu'à présent des dissensions se font
jour au sein de la ligue les plus
extrémistes demande au duc de mayenne de
procéder à l'élection d'un roi
catholique et d'accepter les
revendications de leurs alliés espagnols
les habsbourgs la frange modérée du
parti commence quant à elle à encourager
la réconciliation avec henri iv le plan
de l'ambassadeur espagnol qui consiste à
placer l'infante d'espagne sur le trône
ne fait que développer le sentiment
nationaliste des français
la france veut un roi un roi français
est catholique
c'est donc dans ces circonstances que le
roi précipite les choses il décide de
faire le saut périlleux justement pour
couper court aux prétentions des autres
princes voir princesse à la couronne de
france c'est une conversion largement
politique henri de navarre a toujours su
qu'on en arriverait là pour être roi
il doit être catholique sacrifier sa
religion la foi que lui a transmis sa
mère jeanne d'albret et ce pour le bien
du pays
il n'y a qu'à travers cette conversion
qu'il pourrait instaurer la liberté de
culte pour tous on vous dépeint toujours
en 1/4 comme quelqu'un qui pour des
raisons d'opportunité devient catholique
en disant paris vaut bien une messe
c'est la phrase qui lui est toujours
prêté qui en fait une phrase qu'il n'a
jamais prononcé on la trouve dans aucune
de ces lettres ni dans les propos qui
ont été rapportés
c'est quand même une philosophie et une
phrase qui résume à peu près bien ce
qu'il pensait mais en réalité ce qu'il
voulait toujours cette idée fixe
s'installer au louvre retrouver un
royaume
à peu près pas s'y fier il fallait pas
s'y fier quand on est protestant il faut
pas s'y fier faut donner des gages au
camp d'en face est à dire aux
catholiques
et puis il ya une autre idée qui est qui
peut souligner c'est que chez les
protestants et protestants il était
contre l'idolâtrie c'était contre le
pouvoir des religieux est contre le port
royal si et quand on veut être roi de
france et ben il vaut mieux du parti
catholique
on sait que ce choix lui coûta beaucoup
dans une lettre à sa maîtresse il révèle
la lourde de signification de cet acte
demain je vais accomplir un saut
périlleux
la majorité de la france est catholique
si lui veut faire partie de la majorité
des français il faut qu'ils se
convertissent alors ils acceptent de se
jouer de jouer le jeu de la conversion
et de se faire reconnaître comme
catholiques à saint denis le 25 juillet
15 193 dans la basilique de saint denis
leroy abjure la religion réformée et
reçoit l'absolution
[Musique]
le soir même le ciel de paris est
illuminé par les nombreux feux de joie
allumé par une population en délire au
cours de l'hiver la cause du roi a
continué à progresser mais une part
importante du royaume uni est opposé
cette fois encore henry va mettre à
profit son instinct politique et au lieu
d'attendre l'assentiment total de la
population
il va utiliser le couronnement pour
obtenir son accord les portes de reims
où a lieu habituellement les
couronnements lui reste fermé
la ville est aux mains de la ligue mais
comme une ampoule d'huile sacré se
trouve à tour le 27 février 15 194
henriette enfin couronné en la
cathédrale de chartres
henry savait que l'esprit de vengeance
empêcherait que s'installe une paix
durable
pour éviter cela à l'exception des plus
virulents leeger qui sont bannis tous
les autres sont amnistiés pour les
crimes commis durant les guerres c'est
un acte de clémence sans précédent en
pardonnant à ses ennemis il espère
gagner leur allégeance
mais cela va se révéler plus compliqué
henri iv est un roi soldats mais ce
n'est pas qu'un soldat c'est un
politique à ses fins qui s'est négociée
qui sait pardonner et qui s'est passé
des alliances avec ses anciens
adversaires et c'est ce qu'il fait en
particulier avec les villes l'yeuse qui
se rallient il pardonne ou bien avec les
grands seigneurs catholique de la ligue
à qui il va également pardonner à qui il
va même donner des pensions des dons
assez important pour oublier le passé
une mène une politique de clémence qui
surprend d'ailleurs une politique de
clémence qui va être jugé comme inspiré
par dieu pour être prudente la stratégie
n'en est pas moins efficace puisque en
moins d'un an
il retrouve plus de la moitié de son
royaume auparavant sous la domination de
la libye
enfin 15 100 94 le trésor a été épuisée
pour acheter la ligne le manque de
soutien et une tentative d'assassinât
dans les derniers jours de l'année
le rand déprimé
la dépression du roi liés au long combat
mené pour se faire accepter sur le trône
a sans nul doute influencé sa décision
de punir l'espagne pour les années où
elle ravage à la france il avait
beaucoup à perdre dans cette opération
mais aussi tout à gagner
cela lui permettra d'unir le pays de
regagner ses amis protestants et de
rallier peut-être davantage de
catholiques derrière lui henri déclare
officiellement la guerre à l'espagne en
janvier 15 195
l'une de ses premières victoires à
fontaine française le 5 juin 15 195 est
suivie d'une bonne nouvelle le pape
désire se réconcilier avec lui henry
retrouve sa bonne humeur habituelle et
son optimisme
le roi est réveillée au louvre par la
nouvelle que la france a perdu amiens
contre l'espagne il cache ses craintes
et rassemble avec confiance ses
dernières forces pour reconquérir la
ville
cinq mois plus tard les espagnols 7 en
face du siège et prouvant que leur
inflige henri iv le 25 septembre
ils reconnaissent leur défaite et se
retire officiellement damien loras de
france n'a pas seulement retrouver la
ville il a aussi gagné la loyauté et
l'admiration de son peuple
l'espagne est avide de paix et
s'empressent d'entamer des négociations
tandis que les négociations suivent leur
cours
henry se tourner vers le problème
intérieur le plus urgent la
revendication de liberté religieuse des
huguenots
il ne peut se permettre d'ignorer plus
longtemps la montée des tensions
mécontents les protestants représente
une menace pour la paix on établit les
termes d'un accord et le 13 avril 15 198
henri iv signe l'édit de nantes qui met
fin à 30 années de lutte pour la liberté
de culte
les huguenots sont entièrement amnistié
des crimes commis pendant la guerre
civile et obtiennent la garantie de
leurs droits civiques et de leur liberté
de conscience
[Musique]
les adeptes de la religion réformée ont
maintenant le droit d'exercer librement
leur culte de façon privée partout en
france et de façon publique dans 200
villes désignées
en outre ils peuvent désormais hérité de
bien se livrent au commerce fréquenté
les écoles et les universités et être
traitée avec équité dans les hôpitaux
les protestants sont reconnus comme une
entité politique avec ses propres villes
fortifiées et ses garnisons financé par
la couronne pour garantir sa sécurité
henri iv établi la coexistence non
violente de deux confessions dont une
est légitime et pas l'autre mais il
devient quand même grâce à l'édit de
nantes ce symbole ce souverain symbole
de l'exercice de la tolérance et
j'allais dire d'un pouvoir politique qui
parvient à imposer la tolérance à des
sujets partagé entre deux confessions
religieuses
cette politique audacieuse de liberté
religieuse va devenir la plus grande
réussite du règne d'henri iv
[Musique]
un mois après la proclamation de l'édit
de nantes est signé le traité de vervins
qui met fin définitivement à la guerre
avec l'espagne à la fin du siècle près
de 12 ans après la mort d'henri iii à
saint cloud henri iv est enfin souverain
dans son royaume
pendant très longtemps il a eu un petit
peu et est assis entre deux chaises
entre le parti huguenot le parti de me
catholique mais là ça y est il a réussi
à faire la synthèse à regrouper tout le
monde et à faire en sorte que la france
soit en paix et il est reconnu comme roy
est comme un grand roi mais reste la
question de la reine en 15 99 le roi
tombe gravement malade et chacun se rend
compte du cataclysme qui s'abattrait sur
la france s'il venait à mourir sans
héritier à 46 ans il lui faut une épouse
digne de son rang en 15 100 91 henry
entame une relation avec gabrielle
d'estrées
[Musique]
gabrielle d'estrées était la maîtresse
de son grand écuyer bellegarde et
bellegarde un jour dit à son ami henry
j'ai rencontré une femme qui est
merveilleuse
henry lui dit je veux la voir et ils
l'emmènent au château de cuivre et en
tombe amoureux immédiatement sur le
moment de la petite gabrielle d'estrées
qui était disait-il une vénus picardo
rondeurs flamande et il dit à bellegarde
bon écoute c'est terminé pour toi tu me
la laisse elle restera encore pendant
quelques temps du dernier bien avec
bellegarde mais elle finit par céder à
l'assistance d'henri iv qui pourtant
elle le disait elle-même santé santé de
de l'ale et du goût c'est bon mais il a
pris les leçons toilettes pour pouvoir
achever de la séduire et il va vivre
avec quelle merveilleuse histoire
d'amour il lui fera d'ailleurs trois
enfants elle sera son plus grand amour
et aura beaucoup d' influence sur les
décisions importantes qu henry devra
prendre c'est elle qui le convainc de
renoncer à sa foi protestante qu'il
conseille sully comme premier ministre
et bien qu'elle fût catholique elle lui
inspirera l'édit de nantes sa belle
maîtresse lui a dit un jour je crains
toujours de ne jamais vous retrouvez de
vous apprendre que vous avez été blessé
à mort on ferait mieux de signer
définitivement la paix avec un édit de
tolérance et ses poussées à gabrielle
d'estrées qu'il va donc à nantes signé
s'était dit merveilleux contre
l'accoutumée les intérêts de l'état
henry sans tête depuis plusieurs années
à vouloir épouser sa maîtresse fort de
la confirmation que marguerite de valois
accepte d'annuler leur mariage leur
couple pense que tout est en place pour
exaucer ses voeux
mais une semaine avant le mariage
gabriel succombe brusquement à une
mystérieuse maladie
sans doute une prééclampsie provoqué par
sa quatrième grossesse handicap n'était
pas un simple coureur de jupons c'était
un amoureux qui est créé de très belles
lettres d'amour et qui a eu plusieurs
patients successives et et gabrielle
d'estrées est certainement sa plus
grande passion pendant neuf ans le roi
lui a été fidèle et quand elle meurt il
écrit la racine de mon coeur est morte
et ne reprendra plus
[Musique]
après la perte de son grand amour le roi
âgé maintenant de 45 ans ressemble un
vieillard cinq ans de luttes et de
guerre l'ont profondément marqué tandis
que ce ministre lui cherche activement
une prétendante à la hauteur ces
courtisans se pressent pour le distraire
avec une nouvelle maîtresse c'est la
belle est impitoyable henriette
d'entragues qui est élue elle est sans
aucun doute la plus dépourvu de morale
et la plus rusés des maîtresses du roi
celui ci tombe aussitôt dans sa toile et
il ne s'en échappe rats que bien des
années plus tard on ne sait pas dans
quelle mesure elle n'a pas trempé dans
les multiples complots qui ont armé le
bras de ravaillac n'y a des doutes là
dessus il ya quelques témoignages
étrange
à ce sujet on sait qu'elle a conçu un
très fort dépit de n'avoir pas pu
épouser le roi à la mort de gabrielle
d'estrées parce que le roi en définitive
choisi quelqu'un qu'il ne connaissait
pas mais le peuple et l'état réclame un
mariage qui assurerait un héritier
légitime
sans cela tous les efforts d'henry pour
sauver le pays de l'autodestruction
s'avère rev 1 malgré les doutes qu'il
éprouve à épouser quelqu'un de la
famille de catherine de médicis
ils acceptent d'accélérer les
négociations avec le grand duc de
toscane qui serait prêt à lui accorder
la main de sa fille marie de médicis
l'importante dote de la demoiselle
permettra de rembourser la dette de la
france envers le duc qui avait financé
la lutte contre la ligue au printemps 16
cents en apprenant les fiançailles du
roi avec la riche florentine sa
maîtresse entre dans une rage folle en
octobre 16 cents
marie de médicis épouse le roi par
procuration depuis florence impatiente
elle s'embarque ensuite pour livourne
puis peu après pour marseille plus tard
rubens peindre à l'arrivée et
majestueuse de marie sur les côtes
françaises
mais en vérité l'absence de l'époux et
carte a'tout semblant de cérémonie déçu
d'avoir fait ce voyage éprouvant dans un
froid glacial sans escorte ni accueil
digne de son rang
marie est heureusement surprise de
trouver en son roi un mari aimant
attentif et respectueux
leur première rencontre à lyon le 9
décembre semble être un succès avant
même de rentrer à paris pour préparer
l'arrivée de la reine le roi annonce
avec bonheur que son épouse est enceinte
la jeune florentine envisage avec
optimisme l'avenir de son nouveau pays
mais la passion du roi pour sa maîtresse
n'est pas éteinte
en fait si on rit décide de prendre la
route avant son épouse
c'est qu'il a projeté un rendez vous
secret avec henriette et lorsqu un peu
plus tard il la quittera pour rejoindre
sa femme
elle sera également enceinte un dauphin
futur louis xiii n'est en septembre
henry embrasse marie épuisé par la mise
au monde et la félicite de s'être
acquitté si vite de son devoir envers
son roi et la france les inquiétudes
quant à l'absence d'un héritier prenne
fin la reine est fier d'avoir pu donner
à henri quelque chose dans sa maîtresse
était incapable durant plusieurs années
le roi ne cessa de se quereller avec les
deux femmes de sa vie et de chercher
consolation auprès de nouvelles
conquêtes
après s'être enfin libérer
définitivement des grives d'henriette il
rencontrera à 56 ans le dernier amour de
sa vie
charlotte de montmorency âgé alors de 15
ans elle est trop jeune pour paraître à
la cour et pour paraître à la cour il
faudrait qu'elle soit mariée donc il
décide de la marier
il va la mariée à keep aux petits
princes de condé en brie le petit prince
de condé qui selon lui était inoffensif
puisqu'il passait pour préférer les
beaux éphèbes au bnd jeune fille mais
que s'est il passé bien partir du moment
où condé a épousé la petite charlotte il
est tombé follement amoureux d'elle il
la kidnappe et il disparaît à bruxelles
avec elle et c'est d'ailleurs charlotte
qui sera la maman du grand prince de
condé que l'on connaîtra sous le règne
de louis xiv
henry aura beaucoup d'enfants auprès
desquels il pourra se détendre
marie de médicis lui donnera six enfants
dont quatre survivront jusqu'à l'âge
adulte mais il aura aussi des enfants de
ses maîtresses les trois enfants de son
grand amour
la malheureuse gabrielle d'estrées qui
mourut enceinte
les deux enfants d'henriette
d'entraygues et les bâtards issus de ces
nombreux autres liaisons
ils seront tous élevés ensemble par les
gouvernantes royal car il refusa de les
séparer
comme c'était la coutume ils grandiront
à saint germain en laye et il les aimera
tous également la passion du roi pour sa
progéniture est reflétée dans le récit
de l'ambassadeur d'espagne qui venant
s'entretenir avec lui le trouve à quatre
pattes dans la pièce avec quelques
petits sur son dos il venait lui même
joué avec eux ils se promenaient à
quatre pattes il les mettait sur ses
épaules
il est transporté comme ça ils les époux
juillet il rend levait les poudres et
cheveux voilà c'était un très très bon
papa
[Musique]
henri iv se voyait lui-même comme le
libérateur et le restaurateur de la
france l'impact dévastateur de la guerre
civile fut atténuées par des années
d'inflation que ressentir toutes les
classes sociales
henri mis en place rapidement un conseil
de 12 membres parmi lesquels sully
infatigable et loyal serviteur du pays
et grands administrateurs avec sully
henry travailla d'abord à restaurer
l'économie française en mettant en
oeuvre une fiscalité plus efficace et
remettant de l'ordre dans les finances
de l'état henri iv se trouve à la tête
d'un royaume martyrisé kia dont la
population a stagné dont les ressources
agricoles ont baissé
le peuple est désabusé par toutes ces
années de privations par les pestes
également qu'ils ont marqué le roi doit
reconstruire son royaume il va mener une
politique fiscale intelligente mais très
ferme néanmoins en baissant les impôts
directs
la taille mais en augmentant les
contributions indirectes qui ont l'air
d'être un peu plus facilement supporter
par les sujets mais il ne faut pas
cacher que cette politique va provoquer
un certain nombre de révolte un examen
plus approfondi des impôts des
privilèges et des lois devait
inévitablement toucher au portefeuille
de la noblesse et éveiller les
ressentiments henry savait qu'il ne
pouvait faire entièrement disparaître
les rentes et exonérations à laquelle
celle-ci était accoutumé le premier roi
bourbon va se positionner en père du
peuple
à ce titre il va défendre les projets
destinés à améliorer la vie de ces
sujets c'est ainsi qu'en ce sens il dit
à un visiteur
si dieu me donne encore longtemps vie je
ferais qu'il n'y aura point de
laboureurs à mon royaume qui n'est le
moyen de mettre la poule en son pot le
dimanche
le roi sait que le succès de la france
dépend du succès de ceux qui travaillent
pour elle cet engagement envers les
hommes ordinaires est la raison pour
laquelle henri iv est le seul roi de
france dont la mémoire soit restée
vivante dans l'esprit des pauvres après
la révolution
si la france veut prospérer il lui faut
exporter un maximum et importer un
minimum henri iv voit donc dans
l'agriculture le projet le plus urgent
c'est en se basant sur sur l'agriculture
qui la dessert relever la france 2 l'a
ensuite viendra l'artisanat et on va
tracer des routes etc
enfin il fait il donne vraiment un coup
un renouveau à coudre nouveau à son
royaume
contrairement à son petit fils louis xiv
il encourage la noblesse à quitter la
cour et à s'établir sur ses terres trop
longtemps négligé pour y reconstruire
les ateliers et les ferme en ruine pour
développer le commerce
il fait réparer les routes construire un
nouveau système de route bordée d'arbres
de nouveaux ponts des écluses des quais
et creuser de nouveaux canaux la guerre
et ses conséquences a rendu la france
dépendante d'autres pays pour certaines
denrées henry en réduit l'importation en
stimulant la production nationale des
matières premières comme la laine le
tissu le fer et l'acier sont au centre
de cette préoccupation henri iv ne
sous-estiment pas l'importance de
construire des édifices témoignage de la
grandeur des bourbons le roi fait de
nouveau de paris une grande ville
entre 15 195 et 16 110 il construit le
pont neuf
enjambant la seine
il relie encore aujourd'hui la rive
droite et la rive gauche
un autre projet qui lui tient à coeur
fut le château de fontainebleau avec ces
deux cours
la galerie de diane la galerie des
serres et les jardins longeant le grand
canal
peuplée de statues de bronze et de
fontaines la politique de reconstruction
d'henri iv passe par des réalisations
monumentales tout à fait importante
alors que ses prédécesseurs charles neuf
henry 3 ans à cause des guerres civiles
n'avaient pas beaucoup bâti henri iv va
bâtir beaucoup il va achever un certain
nombre d'ouvragés d'art à paris on parle
aujourd'hui en art comme on architecture
de style henri iv la vision du roi
comprend la planification urbaine et la
santé publique
il fait élargir et paver les rues sales
développée l'acheminement de l'eau
construire un certain nombre d'hôpitaux
et dans les dernières années de sa vie
il tente d'améliorer les logements
il construit la place royale connu
depuis 1800 sous le nom de place des
vosges mais son projet amorcé en 16 108
pour reloger et mettre au travail les
pauvres de la capitale
dans un tout nouveau quartier sera
abandonné à sa mort
l'objectif ultime d'henri iv comme
l'évoquent sully dans ses mémoires était
un projet d'organisation de l'europe
qu'on appellera plus tard le grand
dessein l'idée était d'avoir une
confédération de pays présidé par un
empereur et lui est doté d'un traité de
paix et d'assistance mutuelle
on a prêté à henri iv l'idée de ce qu'on
appelle un grand dessein comment
contentons par ce grand dessein il
s'agirait d'une sorte de confédération
européenne qui nous permettrait un
système de stabilité des équilibres
entre les grands états d'europe et ce
qui permettrait à henri iv roi de france
d'éviter la tutelle de l'empereur la
tutelle des puissants prince de la
maison de habsbourg une alliance entre
les états autres des puissances de
taille moyenne en évitant qu'il y ait un
état qui prennent la tête sur les autres
c'est ce qu'on appelle le grand dessein
darrigade si l'on en croit son ministre
suit pourquoi henric est non at il
jamais parlé lui-même n'a pas parlé au
parlement où il n'a pas parlé dans ces
lettres
est-ce que sully a voulu justifier cette
guerre un peu folle contre le trichet
l'espagne en en un an mettant en avant
ce grand dessein royal après dix ans de
paix henry a hâte de remonter en selle
mais parler de guerre rouvre d'anciennes
blessures
certains craignent que le roi ne met
inutilement en péril la bonne santé d'un
et à restaurer
plus que jamais paris représente un
danger on dit qu'henry est retombé dans
une de ces phases de mélancolie il
craint d'être assassiné s'il ne quitte
paris pour se battre il accepte de
confier à sa femme la régence tandis
qu'ils s'éloignent pour traiter d'
affaire d'état
tout est prêt pour qu'elle soit
couronnée mais encore malgré ses
pressentiments il est forcé d'attendre
enfin la cérémonie a lieu le 13 mai les
récits disent que le roi est heureux de
voir sa femme couronnée
[Musique]
mais quelques jours plus tôt il lui fit
part de ses prémonitions à propos de sa
mort imminente
le 14 mai 16 110 le roi devait se rendre
à l'arsenal chez son ami ministre sully
il était agité et hésité à partie il
pris congé de la reine en l'embrassant
plusieurs fois avant de se résoudre à
monter dans son carrosse
il sort de lure et s'engage
peu après rue de la ferronnerie et la
rue de la ferronnerie
il ya un embouteillage une charrette et
renverser le carrosse est arrêté le roi
n'a pas voulu au départ du louvre il n'a
pas voulu d'escort et peu juste une
escorte extrêmement simple quatre
cavaliers et il est au milieu de la
foule en fête
et là il ya quelqu'un qui arrive avec un
poignard qui monte sur une petite borne
il y avait beaucoup de petites banques
pour monter à cheval servi à monter à
cheval
il monte sur une borne une jambe sur une
borne une jambe sur la roue du carrosse
et poignante trois fois le roi le roi
dit ce n'est rien et où l'on fasse ma
trace de sang et il me semble tout de
suite
il y avait devant le carrosse chevalier
qui s'appelait le baron courtomer qui
était un petit peu en avant garde qui
voulaient aller prévenir sully à
l'arsenal de l'arrivée du roi quand le
baron en tournant la tête a vu que le
carrosse était immobilisé par la
charrette deux fois puis ensuite il ya
eu un attroupement autour du carrosse
parce que j'avais là ça 5 des pères
n'obtenait
que tout le monde tenait que la foule
après voulait lyncher etc
le baron de courtomer tournée bride
il est revenu vers le carrosse et là il
a vu une dizaine d'hommes visiblement
des soldats mais sans uniforme connu
partir à cheval dans les rues adjacentes
et disparaître et ce témoignage qui est
un témoignage vraiment à tester qui a
été fait au procès qui a un peu
intéressé le président du tribunal mais
on à lisbourg bas ils ont disparu on
sait pas qui c'est on sait pas on va pas
plus loin on cherche pas plus loin
c'est un témoignage qui à tout vent
était troublant que faisait ses hommes
en armes autour autour du carrosse
souvenait-il certains pensent que cet
acte avait été commandité par un ennemi
de l'entourage même du roi mais même
sous la torture
le régicide affirmant qu'il avait agi de
son propre chef
la mort soudaine du roi à 56 ans fut une
perte immense
qui sait ce qu'il aurait fait pour la
france s'il avait vécu plus longtemps
malgré le peu de temps dont il avait
disposé il laissait derrière lui une
france forte et opulente
grâce à lui le pays était redevenu
prospère et avait retrouvé sa puissance
militaire le roi a remporté les guerres
de religion si l'on peut dire
il a pacifié son royaume mais il meurt
tragiquement en 1610 assassiné par
ravaillac
le choc est tellement fort les français
sont tellement effrayés ils ont
tellement peur que les guerres civiles
reprennent comme elles avaient eu lieu
pendant trente ans auparavant qu'ils
vont idéalisé assez rapidement la figure
de ce roi pacificateur de ce roi henry
qui a donné la paix au royaume de france
mais pendant assez longtemps le roi a
été jugé avec suspicion par beaucoup du
sud beaucoup de sujets et c'est vraiment
sa mort qui fait de lui une sorte de sa
royale henri iv est enterré à la
basilique de saint denis
[Musique]
sa veuve marie de médicis va assurer la
régence jusqu'en 16e 117 puisque leur
fils le futur louis xiii n'a alors que 9
rue henri iv n'a vécu qu'un peu plus de
dix ans a consacré aux affaires de
l'état
aussi nombre de ces entreprises ne
parviendront pas à terme mais sa vision
de la france et les risques qu'il a pris
pour la réaliser ont posé les bases de
la prospérité future du pays
quatre ans seulement après sa mort on
lui ériger une statue sur le pont neuf
cette statue comme celle de tous les
autres rois de france fut détruite
pendant la révolution et c'est la
première qui fut reconstruite en 1818
henri iv fut incroyablement populaire au
cours de son règne et l'est resté
il a sauvé et reconstruire un pays ruiné
déchirée par des idéologies rival et son
oeuvre lui a survécu
il est le roi de france que l'on cite le
plus souvent parmi bien d'autres 4
expression célèbre ont traversé les
siècles pour entériner l'image du bon
roi henri iv
la première inspire l'affection une
poule au pot tous les dimanches et le
décrit comme l'ami le bienfaiteur de son
peuple
elle témoigne de son attention vers ces
sujets le vert-galant fait référence à
son caractère fougueux et à l'insatiable
coureur de jupons qu'il était on retient
également et surtout dans la légende
la fameuse poule au pot que lui manger à
sa manière la plupart du temps c'est à
dire la béarnaise quand ils allaient
dormir chez l'habitant et souvent avec
l'habitante les deux autres rendent
compte de sa gloire militaire et de son
souci de préserver l'unité du pays ne
perd des points de vue mon panache blanc
évoque l'image du fringant chefs
militaires et paris vaut bien une messe
reflète sa volonté sans faille de mettre
fin aux guerres de religion et d'unifier
la france il est surnommé le bon roi
henri
ou le vert-galant ou parfois henry de
grands jusqu'à sa mort henry garde à une
jeunesse d'esprit et une vigueur
exceptionnelle mais son combat long et
difficile pour les droits des huguenots
avait marqué son visage quand il succéda
en 15 189 à un reee 3 et qu'il devint
henri iv il était un roi sans royaume un
mari 100 femmes un général sans fortune
et il lui était impossible comme il ne
compris avec le temps de changer cela
tant qu'il restait protestants pour être
roi
il devait devenir catholique il se plia
donc à ce qui était exigé de lui une
fois roi il pu atteindre son objectif
rétablir la paix dans le royaume et
assurer la liberté religieuse pour son
peuple
henri de bourbon roi de france et de
navarre pour être le préféré des
français n'en est pas moins critiquable
certains ont interprété la phrase paris
vaut bien une messe
comme un désir brûlant de pouvoir mais
il n'avait pas d'autres recours et cela
lui coûte à beaucoup il a aussi été taxé
de manque d'intelligence
s'il ne connaissait pas les manières de
la haute société
il n'était ni naïf ni idiot comme
certains le pensaient c'était un fin
stratège en politique il parvint à
survivre parmi les dangers et les
complots et prouva qu'il n'était pas
dépourvu du sens des réalités
au cours des siècles
certains ont considéré les
contradictions de son caractère comme de
graves insuffisances
pendant que ses admirateurs y voyait une
preuve de sa complexité et de son
humanité sa gaieté et son apparente
insouciance voisinaient avec une
profonde capacité de réflexion une
jeunesse d'esprit et une grande sagesse
et maturité
son ami le célèbre poète huguenots
agrippa d'aubigné dit à son propos
la france a perdu en lui le plus grand
roi qu'elle ait jamais connu il n'était
pas sans défauts ni sans doute mais en
échange il possédait des vertus
inégalable il lui fallut une
détermination une ténacité une patience
et un charisme extraordinaire pour tirer
son pays du cercle vicieux de
l'autodestruction
il fallait aussi une vision une
intégrité et le sens du compromis pour
reconstruire un état déchiré par la
guerre henry pensait que dieu l'avait
appelé pour être roi rétablir la paix et
la prospérité dans son pays bien aimé
il n'était pas un homme parfait mais il
répondu à l'appel et accomplit son
destin
[Musique]